picture your dream vacation maybe you're
dying to go to Rio for Carnaval or you
really just want to hang out on a
Mexican beach or maybe you're going to
join me in New Orleans for Jazz Fest now
I know it's less pleasant but picture
for a moment one of the most violent
places on earth did anyone think of the
same place Brazil is the most violent
country in the world today more people
have been dying there over the last
three years than in Syria and in Mexico
more people have died over the last 15
years than in Iraq or Afghanistan in New
Orleans more people per capita are dying
than in war-torn Somalia the fact is war
only results in about 18 percent of
violent deaths worldwide today you are
more likely to die violently if you live
in a middle-income democracy with high
levels of income inequality and serious
political polarization the United States
has four of the 50 most violent cities
on earth now this is a fundamental
alteration and the nature of violence
historically but it's also an
opportunity because while few people can
do much to end war violence in our
democracies is our problem and while
regular voters are a big part of that
problem
we're also key to the solution now I
work at a think-tank the Carnegie
Endowment for international peace where
I advise governments on what to do about
violence but the dirty secret is most
policymakers haven't figured out these
changes to violence today they still
believe that the worst violence happens
in countries at war or places that are
too poor too weak to fight violence and
control crime and that had been my
assumptions
- but if you look at a map of the most
violent places on earth you see
something strange some of them are at
war and a few are truly failed States
the violence in these places is horrific
but they happen of small populations so
it actually affects few people then
there's South Africa Brazil Venezuela
these places are not poor maybe they're
weak my research assistant and I mapped
places based on how well they delivered
on World Bank projects and whether they
could get public services to their
people and if you did well on both of
those if you could get sanitation and
electricity to your people and deliver
vaccines you were in the upper
right-hand quadrant and then we overlaid
that with a map of places where
journalists were being murdered some
were happening in weak states but an
awful lot of journalists were being
killed and places plenty capable of
protecting them I traveled to every
settled continent on earth
comparing places that had faced massive
violence and recovered and those that
hadn't and I kept seeing the same
pattern I came to call it privilege
violence because it happened in highly
unequal democracies where a small group
of people wanted to hold on to
inordinate power and privilege and if
they didn't think they could get those
policies passed the voters sometimes
they would turn to violent groups for
help drug cartels would finance their
campaigns organized criminals would help
them get out the vote gangs would
suppress the vote and in exchange they'd
be given free rein and violence would
grow take Venezuela it's the most
violent country in the world today if
you look at deaths per capita 20 years
ago the current regime gained power and
legitimate elections but they didn't
want to risk losing it and so they
turned to gangs called colectivos for
help the gangs were told to get out the
vote for the government and forced
people to vote for the regime in some
neighborhoods and keep opposition voters
away from the polls and others in an
exchange they'd be given control but if
criminals have control then police and
courts can't do their
jobs so the second stage in privilege
violence is that courts and police are
weakened and politicians politicized
budgets hiring firing so that they and
the violent groups that they collude
with stay out of jail now
pretty soon good cops leave and many
that remain become brutal they start off
usually with rough justice they kill a
drug dealer that they think will be let
off by the corrupt courts but over time
the worst of them realize that there
will be no repercussions from the
politicians they're in bed with and they
go into business for themselves and
Venezuela and nearly one in three
murders is by the security services now
the poor hit hardest by violence all
over the world but they're hardly going
to turn to such predatory cops for help
so they tend to form vigilante groups
but armed a bunch of eighteen year old
boys and pretty soon they devolve into
gangs over time other gangs come in
mafias come in and they offer to protect
people from the other criminals and from
the police
unlike the state the criminals often try
to buy legitimacy they give charity they
solve disputes sometimes they even build
subsidized housing the last stage of
privileged violence happens when regular
people start committing a significant
portion of the murder bar fights in
neighborhood arguments turned deadly
when violence has become normal and
repercussions have evaporated to
outsiders the culture looks depraved as
if something is deeply wrong with those
people but any country can become this
violent when the government is by turns
absent and predatory
actually that's not quite true it takes
one more step for this level of violence
to reign it takes mainstream society to
ignore the problem you'd think that
would be impossible that violence at
this level would be unbearable but it's
actually quite bearable the people like
you and me that's because
in every society in the world even the
most violent violence is highly
concentrated it happens to people on the
wrong side of town people who are poor
often darker often from groups that are
marginalized groups that mainstream
society can separate ourselves from
violence is so concentrated that were
shocked when the pattern deviates in
Washington DC in 2001 a young white
college-educated intern went missing
after a hike in Northwest DC and her
case was in the papers nearly every day
on the other side of town
a black man had been killed every other
day that year most of those cases never
made the papers even once
middle-class society buys their way out
of violence we live in better
neighborhoods
some people buy private security and we
also tell ourselves a story we tell
ourselves that most of the people who
are killed are probably involved in
crime themselves by believing that
somehow some people deserve to be
murdered otherwise good people allow
ourselves to live in places where life
chances are so deeply skewed we allow
ourselves because after all what else
can you do well it turns out quite a lot
because violence today is not largely
the result of war but is because of
rotten politics and our democracy's
regular voters are the greatest force
for change consider the transformation
of Bogota in 1994 Colombia's incoming
president was caught taking millions of
dollars in campaign contributions from
the Cali drug cartel and the capital was
overrun with gangs and paramilitary
groups but fed up voters overcame really
rabid partisanship and they delivered
nearly 2/3 of the vote to an independent
candidate enough to really overcome
business as usual on mayor Marcus's
first day in office
the police barely bothered to even brief
him on homicide and when he asked why
they just shrugged and said it's just
criminals killing criminals the corrupt
City Council wanted to give police even
more impunity for brutality it's a
really common tactic that's used
worldwide when politicians want a
posture is tough on crime but don't
actually want to change the status quo
and research shows that backfires all
over the world if you throw a lot of
low-level offenders into jails usually
already overcrowded jails they learn
from each other and they hurt him they
start to control the prisons and from
there the streets instead moccasin sista
that police begin investigating every
death he fought the right-wing City
Council and he abandoned SWAT style
police tactics and he fought the
left-wing unions and fired thousands of
predatory cops honest police were
finally free to do their jobs Marquez
then challenged citizens yes the middle
class to stop opting out of their city
to follow traffic laws and otherwise
behave as if they shared the same
community of faith yes the poor to
uphold social norms against violence
often an immense personal risk and asked
the wealthy to give 10% more in taxes
voluntarily 63,000 people did and at the
end of the decade that spanned mayor
Marcus's two terms in office homicide in
Bogota was down 70 percent
people in places with the most violence
whether it's Colombia or the United
States can make the biggest difference
the most important thing we can do is
abandon the notion that some lives are
just worth less than others
that someone deserves to be raped or
murdered because after all they did
something they stole or they did
something to lay on themselves in prison
where that kind of thing happens this
devaluing of human life a devaluing we
barely admit even to ourselves is what
allows the whole downward spiral to
begin it's what allows a bullet shot in
a gang war and Rio to lodge in the head
of a two year old girl climbing on a
jungle gym nearby and it's what allows a
SWAT team hunting from meth dealer in
Georgia to throw a flashbang grenade
into the crib of a little boy
exploding near his face and maiming him
for life the fact is most violence
everywhere happens to people on the
wrong side of town at the wrong time and
some of those people are from
communities that we consider quite
different some of them are people who
have done horrible things but reducing
violence begins with privileges every
human life both because it's right and
because only by prising each life is
worthy of at least due process can we
create societies in which the lives of
innocence are safe ii recognize that
today inequality within our countries is
a vastly greater cause of violence than
war between countries the inequality
leads to violence for a whole host of
reasons but one of them is that it lets
us separate ourselves from what's
happening on the other side of town
those of us who are middle-class are
wealthy who are benefitting from these
systems have to change them at immense
cost to ourselves we have to pay enough
taxes and then demand that our
governments put good teachers in other
kids schools and well-trained police to
protect other people's neighborhoods but
if
that's not going to do any good if the
government is stealing the money or
fueling the violence and so we also need
better politicians with better
incentives the fact is we actually know
a lot about what it takes to reduce
violence it's policies like putting more
cops in the few places where most
violence occurs but they don't fit
easily into the boxes of the left or the
right and so you need really honest
politicians who are willing to buck
knee-jerk partisanship and implement
solutions and if we want good
politicians to run we need to start
respecting politicians there's also a
lot we can do to fight priviledge
violence in other countries the most
violent regimes tend to be fueled by
drugs and then they launder the profits
through financial systems in New York
and London through real estate
transactions and through high-end
resorts if you use drugs know your
supply chain top to bottom or admit the
amount of pain you're willing to cause
others for your own pleasure meanwhile I
would love to see one of those tourist
sites team up with investigative
journalists and create a little tiny
icon right next to the one for free
Wi-Fi and if a place has a swimming pool
there could be a little tiny gun for
likely criminal money-laundering front
but until then if you're booking a place
in a dangerous country whether that's
Jamaica or New Orleans do a little web
research see if you can see any criminal
ties and to make that easier support
legislation that makes our financial
systems more transparent things like
banning anonymous company ownership now
this all probably sounds pretty quixotic
kind of like recycling your cans just a
tiny drop in the ocean of a gigantic
problem but that's actually a
misconception homicide has been falling
for centuries battle deaths have been
dropping for decades in places where
people have demanded change violent
death has fallen from Columbia to New
York City where homicide is down 85
percent since 1990 the fact is violence
will always be with us but is not a
constant it has been falling for
centuries and it could fall further
faster could it drop by 25% in the next
quarter century a third many of us
actually think it could I think of all
the kids who grow up with their dads all
the families that get their sisters back
their brothers all that needs is one
small push it needs us to care thank you
[Applause]
[Music]